o que é paz
certamente perguntar se a cada um de
vocês aqui nesta sala o que é paz pra
vocês quais imagens viriam a mente de
cada um de vocês e se eu fosse além e se
eu perguntasse a vocês o que é violência
com as imagens estão surgindo a mente de
vocês
quando eu falo a palavra violência
fazendo esse exercício
pensem agora e qual dessas duas imagens
e qual dessas duas palavras surgem o
maior número de imagens de
representações e quais são as mais
diversas mas ou violência
guardem essa informação que logo mais
vamos votar nela mas ela vai ser muito
importante para pensar a paz ea
violência na nossa sociedade
contemporânea
mas antes de falar sobre isso eu
gostaria de contar uma história uma
história e joaquim na verdade joaquim é
o meu filhinho de quase dois anos ou
como gosta de chamá lo na escolinha o
joca ro o ranking já que ele é metade
brasileiro metade espanhol eo joaquim
desde que nasceu sempre ouviu histórias
e contos de fadas inusitados
desconstruídas reinventados e que
buscavam inverter a lógica da violência
na nossa cultura
para joaquim a branca de neve era uma
guerreira que defende a floresta da
degradação ambiental
até parece que eu sou uma mãe pouco nerd
né
mas na verdade a minha preocupação era
que claro
joaquim estava construindo seu
repertório ele ainda é uma criança de
dois anos
mas algo me dizia me diz que certamente
ele será uma criança com uma nova
sensibilidade e que vai questionar a
violência que também está dentro da
nossa cultura no nosso cotidiano no
nosso dia a dia
e foi assim que nós aprendemos a olhar
para as canções infantis ou atirei o pau
no gato
mas o gato não morreu na verdade se
transformou em eu brinquei de bola com o
gato e o gato se escondeu e assim nós
fomos criando uma outra lógica para que
ele pudesse olhar o mundo não uma bolha
isolado do mundo dos conflitos que a
própria realidade da sociedade impõe ao
contrário
a nossa intenção é que ele seja uma
criança preparada para o mundo para
diversidade para a violência e que seja
capaz de questionar as estruturas de
violência que estão aí estão
naturalizados na nossa cultura é
partindo disso que eu me apresento a
vocês eu sou raquel
eu sou pesquisadora da unesp e da
universidade estadual paulista em bauru
pesquisador em estudos para a paz e
comunicação
e é pensando nisso que eu apresento a
vocês a minha linha de pesquisa os
estudos para a paz que como área de
conhecimento e ciência tem quase 100
anos algo muito muito recente muito
jovem quando a gente fala em ciência e
do brasil ainda é mais recente mas que
tem uma preocupação fundamental que é
justamente pensar a violência que está
enraizada naturalizada na nossa
linguagem
naquilo que nós
dizemos que produzimos
cantamos lemos vemos no filme e que
fazem parte do nosso repertório não de
agora mas há séculos e milénios nós
estamos sendo educados numa cultura de
violência
você se lembra das imagens que eu pedi
pra vocês pensarem sobre paz e violência
logo no início certamente muitos de
vocês poderiam dizer que encontraram uma
maior diversidade de representações de
imagens
quando eu falei a palavra violência
porque será
será algo gratuito será que nós
aprendemos a compreender mais a
violência do que a paz a mais
representações sobre a violência na
nossa sociedade e principalmente no
último século
com a intensificação dos meios de
comunicação do que de trás e se essa é
uma verdade como ela se legitima como
ela se constrói na nossa sociedade é
partindo disso que eu cheguei a uma
indagação profunda na minha área de
estudos de pesquisa como comunicadora
quando eu cheguei até esses filósofos
adorno e horkheimer da escola crítica da
comunicação e eles vão dizer essa
citação que pra mim foi um marcador de
águas
eles disseram em 47 do século passado
as máquinas às armas e por fim a
linguagem são os instrumentos que
legitimam a dominação e aí eu estabeleci
uma relação metafórica imediata
primeiro as máquinas as máquinas seriam
a metáfora do nosso sistema produtivo da
cadeia de produção no sistema do capital
que necessariamente vai produzir
desigualdade
afinal nesse sistema do capital é
preciso haver excedentes humanos
na verdade o sistema do capital está
fundamentado na desigualdade daqueles
que detém os meios de produção e aqueles
que vendem a sua força de trabalho
então entende que esse era um mecanismo
de dominação e as armas às armas seria
uma metáfora do nosso sistema de
controle social dos aparatos ideológicos
do estado que nós criamos para controle
da nossa sociedade basta pensar no
exército e na polícia que possuem a
legitimidade do uso da força para o
controle da nossa sociedade mas algo que
nem que tô até porque eu sou
comunicadora foi justamente pensar
porque a linguagem é um instrumento de
dominação de violência porque a
comunicação também produz violência foi
me questionando sobre essas questões que
eu cheguei até os estudos para a paz em
um dos mais importantes documentos das
nações unidas através do seu braço é é
materializado na unesco como sendo o
mesmo que cuida dos temas de educação
cultura e ciência foi o manifesto de
sevilha um documento produzido por
cientistas médicos geneticistas biólogos
do mundo inteiro que estavam preocupados
com uma questão fundamental afinal nós
seres humanos nascemos violentos
nós podemos dizer que o bebê ao nascer
está determinado a ser um indivíduo
violento ou nós aprendemos a ser
violentos e aí fazendo uma distinção
entre violência e agressividade
foi partindo 10 desses questionamentos
que essa conferência internacional
produziu esse importante documento que
vai dizer claramente não
não há nada na nossa biologia humana
o nosso dna que determine que nós
nascemos violentos como algumas teorias
científicas no último século tentaram
comprovar inclusive afirmando que
haveria uma iraquização de raças e
etnias e de culturas e que alguns
indivíduos dessa sociedade estariam
fatalmente determinados a desaparecer
e aí se justifica várias ações violentas
na nossa história humana à escravidão
o extermínio de indígenas até mesmo a
violência que nós hoje vemos nas
minorias que sofrem muitas vezes de
forma silenciosa nas nossas sociedades
do mundo todo e foi então me
questionando sobre isso que de fato o
documento manifesta de sevilha vai dizer
a violência é de fato uma condição
humana que não se encontra nos demais
animais
eu nunca vi um leão construir uma arma
para ferir o outro leão
nesse sentido eu posso pensar que a
agressividade diferente da violência uma
violência legitimada pelos mecanismos
sociais é chamada pela própria política
foi então que eu cheguei a esse senhor
simpático e johann dar o tom
um dos pais fundadores nessa linha de
pesquisa e muito ativo ainda atualmente
que já nos anos 60 vai fundar o primeiro
instituto internacional de pesquisa para
a paz e vai questionar e vai dizer nós
sim precisamos pensar a paz mas
compreendendo os mecanismos da violência
porque barbáries como essa aconteceram
foram reais e foram também legitimados e
naturalizados pela comunicação pela
nossa linguagem
basta pensarmos por exemplo o que é
feito o que fez hitler
com o seu ministro da propaganda muito
preocupado com os temas da comunicação
como o controle social através do cinema
do rádio da literatura e é partindo
disso que o garoto vai chegar a até três
modelos de violência a primeira seria a
violência direta que é aquela violência
que eu consigo identificar vítima e
agressor e eu consigo registrar filmar
fotografar pode ser uma violência
doméstica
a segunda violência a violência
sistêmica e estrutural que é aquela em
que eu só consigo enxergar as vítimas
porque os agressores estão por trás dos
sistemas sociais estão difusos opacos
eu consigo chegar uma fila de
desempregados por exemplo que são
vítimas de um sistema desigual
baseado no capital no acúmulo de capital
e por sim garoto vai dizer que entre as
três
essa é a violência mais sutil mas é
aquela que vai naturalizar e legitimar
as outras duas
a violência cultural porque ela está
presente na nossa vida cotidiana na
nossa linguagem nas expressões
coloquiais nos nossos ditados populares
nos filmes da literatura o que significa
por exemplo quando eu falo a palavra ou
quando eu falo expressão você está na
minha lista negra
você já deve ter ouvido isso ou hoje eu
tive um dia de negro ou por exemplo a
coisa tá preta em o que significa e qual
a implicação de se pensar e associar a
cor negra algo negativo numa sociedade
multicultural como a nossa em que a
maior parte da população brasileira tem
descendência afro descendência
eu estou legitimando a partir da minha
linguagem da minha
comunicação mecanismos de naturalização
e exclusão contra determinadas em que
ponto determinados indivíduos contra
determinadas etnias culturas o que
significa por exemplo cantar a canção a
canção infantil como atirei o pau no
gato
mas o gato não morreu como implicância
de se pensar com implicação de se
associar o cravo brigou com a rosa
debaixo de uma sacada o cravo saiu
ferido ea rosa despedaçada
sempre sobra pior parte para a mulher né
uma sociedade patriarcal a uma violência
direta naturalizado na nossa cultura e
que também impõe uma violência contra os
próprios homens porque se ele não é
hétero ele não é branco
se ele não é bem sucedido ele também
está fora desse modelo
e aí a gente começa a entender que há
uma normativas normatização da linguagem
e dos mecanismos de violência que passa
na nossa cultura
e num país como o nosso que significa
legitimar a violência na nossa linguagem
contra o negro contra a mulher
as pesquisas mostram pesquisa datafolha
de 2017 indica que 503 mulheres sofrem
algum tipo de violência física a cada
hora no brasil
ou esse dado da unesco brasil de 2012
indicam que o risco de uma pessoa negra
será assassinada no brasil é duas vezes
e meia maior que uma pessoa branca
isso já mostra que de fato há uma
violência que passa pela linguagem e se
manifesta de fato na sociedade através
de uma violência direta e estrutural
é nesse sentido que eu pergunta vocês se
a guerra a violência é de fato um
fenômeno humano
como ela se legitima e então quando os
estudos para a paz vamos apontar que é
através da nossa cultura da nossa dos
nossos discursos sociais das artes da
ideologia da religião e até da nossa
própria ciência
nós sabemos o quanto a ciência também se
dedicou a comprovar estruturas de
violência entre determinadas sociedades
é nesse sentido que eu convido todos
vocês a repensarem a linguagem que você
utiliza no dia a dia a desconstruir em
as fórmulas dadas
os ditados populares as expressões
coloquiais as piadas que muitas vezes
são reprodutoras de violência estão
legitimando e naturalizando a violência
na nossa sociedade
é nesse sentido que nós precisamos
aprender a desconstruir o cravo ea rosa
eles não precisavam brigar
eles poderiam sair para brincar atirei o
pau no gato também não precisava ser
assim ele pode ser desconstruído
como eu falei eu tenho feito isso com
joaquim se ele vai ser um pacifista
eu não sei mas certamente será uma
criança que saber a questionar as
estruturas de violência que estão dadas
e naturalizados na nossa sociedade é
preciso reinventar o mundo a olhar o
mundo de ponta cabeça e sermos capazes
de reinventar a nossa linguagem a nossa
comunicação
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]